The formula that we just derived
for the monotonic case
has a nice intuitive explanation
that we will
develop now.
Suppose that g is a monotonic
function of x and that it's
monotonically increasing.
Let us fix a particular x and a
corresponding y so that the
two of them are related as
follows-- y is equal to g of
x, or we could argue in terms
of the inverse function so
that x is equal to h of y.
Recall that h is the inverse
function, that given a value
of y, tells us which one is the
corresponding value of x.
Now let us consider a small
interval in the
vicinity of this x.
Whenever x falls somewhere in
this range, then y is going to
fall inside another
small interval.
The event that x belongs here is
the same as the event that
y belongs there.
So these two events have
the same probability.
And we can, therefore, write
that the probability that Y
falls in this interval is the
same as the probability that X
falls in the corresponding
little interval on the x-axis.
This interval has a certain
length delta 1.
length delta 2.
Now remember our interpretation
of
probabilities of small intervals
in terms of PDFs so
this probability here is
approximately equal to the PDF
of Y evaluated at the point
y times the length of the
corresponding interval.
Similarly, on the other side,
the probability that X falls
on the interval is the
PDF of X times the
length of that interval.
So this gives us already a
relation between the PDF of Y
and the PDF of X, but it
involves those two numbers
delta 1 and delta 2.
How are these two
numbers related?
If x moves up by the amount of
delta 1, how much is y going
to move up?
It's going to move up by an
amount which is delta 1 times
the slope of the function g
at that particular point.
So that gives us one relation
that delta 2 is approximately
equal to delta 1 times the
derivative of the function of
g at that particular x.
However, it's more useful to
work the other way, thinking
in terms of the inverse
function.
The inverse function maps y to
x, and it maps y plus delta to
2 to x plus delta 1.
When y advances by delta 2, x
is going to advance by an
amount which is how much y
advanced times the slope, or
the derivative, of
the function that
maps y's into x's.
And this function is the
inverse function.
So this is the relation that
we're going to use.
And so we replace delta 1 by
this expression that we have
here in terms of delta 2.
And now we cancel the delta
2 from both sides of this
equality, and we obtain the
final formula that the PDF of
Y evaluated at a certain point
is equal to the PDF of x
evaluated at the corresponding
point, or we could write this
as the PDF of X evaluated at the
value x that's associated
to that y that's given by the
inverse function, times the
derivative of the function
h, the inverse function.
And this is just the same
formula as the one that we had
derived earlier using CDFs.
This derivation is
quite intuitive.
It associates probabilities of
small intervals on the x-axis
to probabilities of
corresponding small intervals
on the y-axis.
These two probabilities have to
be equal, and this implies
a certain relation between
the two PDFs.